d'accueillir notre indiqué suivant à
l'invité sans risque je te rassure tout
de suite et je suis sûr que renault vous
y serez attentif puisqu'en 68
quand vous faisiez des sketches de guy
bedos le soir pour vos amis physalies
enfin caméra de william klein le jouet
des sketches de guide aux noms c'est
donner la vie oui oui voilà en même
temps donc il vendait dans la journée
action tu te souviens d'action se
termine
haarde l'orage et où l'orangé et on
appelait renault bague approche c'était
votre surnom à l'époque
pas étonnant que ce soir je vous demande
de rester avec nous pour accueillir
victor hugo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soir vous avez 200 ans est ce que je
peux vous demander comment il était
michel drucker quand il était jeune
n'importe quoi mais qu'il est chaud très
respectueux du cesi thierry ah oui
faudrait que j'en prenne de la graine
bien à 14 ans guy faire quoi à victor je
voulais être chateaubriand ou rien c'est
écrit dans mon journal intime en fait je
voulais surtout être moins 18 ans vous
tombez amoureux d'elle foucher qu'est ce
qui vous a plu chez elle
j'ai d'abord aimé ses joues roses puis
j'ai vu ses chevilles c'était à granby
heures au pardon alors c'est vrai que le
soir la nuit noisetier déchaîné comme
une bête et où il y avait fait l'amour
ma foi à victor comme une bec hellouin
on est loin de drucker nous étions
vierge
on a dix neuf fois gd c'est dire
9 x 9 x beaucoup à la fois c'est juste
pour le mettre en train
et alors quelques années plus tard
adèle vous trompe avec san buzz qui
était pourtant très moche et on
murmurait qu'il avait une malformation
très gênante attendait sa place mais non
non mais il savait susurré les
sentiments mais là inamine avait une
petite [ __ ]
j'ai fait les sous titres quoi c'est
qu'on a bien vu que nous aujourd'hui et
alors la victoire vous rencontré
juliette drouet l'autre femme de votre
vie
quelle quelle phrase digne de plamondon
lui avez-vous écrite n'importe quoi
l'amour qu'il est bête
je crois que je vais finir par me
relâcher habitude il a lutté au jeu soit
bientôt
victor se désole du temps aux effets du
plan dont voilà tu as aimé
c'est plus que vive
je suis pas là l'oeuvre de plamondon à
la trappe pour ça que je connais mieux
victorio tu devrais m'en cindy c'est
vachement bien
vous voilà donc victor avec une épouse
cinq enfants une maîtresse mais vous
restez très très très chaud à vous fait
surprendre en train de sauter une
dénommée leoni qui sera foutu en taule
pour ça vous avez fait quoi pour la
sortir de taule son mari était un
mauvais peintre le roi louis-philippe
était mon ami j'étais père de france
le roi a commenté quelques oeuvres ou
marie qui a retiré sa plainte
ah bah voilà alors ça la monarchie en
messages vers la démocratie
j'ai pas d'idée non tout de suite alors
les havrais playboy à vous noté tous vos
tous vos coups dans un carnet et c'est
comme sa victoire qu'on apprend qu'à 70
ans quand trois jeunes comédiennes
viennent vous voir pour un rôle
vous les recevez à tour de rôle dans
votre chambre oui à 70 ans j'avais écrit
dans mon carnet secret d'audace no
stress et toutes les trois
m
[Applaudissements]
et votre votre dernière conquête c'était
quand tu entrais le 5 avril 1885 deux
mois 2 - avant de morges avait 83 ans
aimer c'est plus que vivre mouche mais
comme dit plamondon
alors malgré tout ça vous n'avez que
cinq enfants et tous avec la même épouse
légitime mais mais finalement ces
enfants est un peu le drame de votre vie
victor non vie je verrai disparaître
quatre enfants est la cinquième devenir
folle veut plus que porter le prix à
payer pour le génie ouais enfin tous les
cas son plan boulot pas de problème à
vous êtes dans le guiness book
le poète le plus prolixe au monde avec
153 1837 vert et en 1831 vous écrivez
donc notre dame de paris
ce qui entraînera les travaux de
restauration de la cathédrale
heureusement vous n'avez pas écrit la
bastille il aurait reconstruite d'une
victoire qui a dit de vous ouais c'est
bien notre dame de paris
mais je préfère la comédie musicale peut
être patrick fiori
s'ils me donnaient encore du boulot dit
un monsieur patrick fiori
je vais je me passe là j'ai l'impression
que je fais une sorte de réussite
asseoir évitez dr texte ancien buteur et
l'obligé toi mais je le regrette
ouais victorz ai pas marre que tout le
monde se fasse de la tune sur votre dos
non je suis grave vénère road runners
pour traduire ses grands bonheurs du
bien de vittorio s unir les graves
manques voilà voilà
alors vous entré à l'académie française
en 1841 à l'âge de 38 ans est-ce que
c'est pas un peu jeune finalement
victoire pour devenir immortel et
n'oublions pas un pur l'académie m'avait
couronner un ces gens et puis que j'ai
dû attendre encore quatre 4 fois ah
ouais pour être élu oui là tout va bien
provoquer un petit peu comme bernard
tapie
vous vous dites et si je faisais de la
politique vous vous dites et si je
faisais de la politique et en 48 en 1840
il doit tourner vous êtes élu député
avec le soutien des conservateurs de
droite 20 mai vous passez rapidement à
gauche par damas mais c'est bien il faut
être fidèle à soi même c'est pas les
girouettes qui tournent ces deux ans
bravo
[Applaudissements]
voilà victor alors très très vite vous
vous opposez à napoléon iii votre tête
est mise à prix est un peu comme
polnareff vous êtes obligé de quitter la
france si on n'est pas que j'aie un
email la résistance au coup d'état de
décembre et que une équipe de tueurs me
chercher ah ouais je veux dire qu'il
avait des couilles pas seulement pour
aller au lit il ya des couilles aussi
pour elle à la chambre bravo alors vous
êtes donc obligé de vous déguiser pour
fuir
vous prenez le costume d'un ouvrier le
passeport au nom de lanvin et vous vivez
trois ans à jersey 15 ans à guernesey et
quand napoléon iii commença à laisser
rentrer certains proscrit en france vous
vous refusez et s'il n'en reste qu'un je
serai celui-là ça c'est d'eddy mitchell
avant
excuse moi mais bon alors du dandy vous
passez au patriarche vous mettez à faire
du spiritisme
c'est un peu zarbi salon va faire
tourner les tables quels sont les
esprits qui ont répondu à vos appels
victor d'abord léopold team votre fille
oui me plie 10 médailles puis
jésus-christ me remets shakespeare
molière puis napoléon ier sont venus me
rendre visite
guernesey juste en tapant juste en
teintant sans public
quand vous sortez les misérables c'est
un triomphe vous n'êtes pas un petit peu
embellie les pauvres non du camp fantine
9 ans étant et ses cheveux pays la
pension de causette
ouais c'est pas embellir les choses là
avait dit allez bon j'essaie de le faire
chier mais bon il a réponse à tout vous
devrez pas quand même qu'à quelques
coïncidences un petit peu
invraisemblable dans les misérables non
c'est la manifestation de dieu d'accord
tu l'as cherché le dispute à éviter ou
ça de ma part victor vont rentrer en
france après la chute de l'empiré
voilà mais à ce point-là paris meurent
de faim et paris est obligé de manger
serre a besoin de sortie comment à ce
moment-là vous par feu vert du
gouvernement je recevais régulièrement
de la viande d'ours ou d'éléphant en
provenance du zoo de paris j'étais
victor hugo c'est bon pour la mémoire
d'éléphant et 200 ans
jugez vous même à barres et ça se passe
bien une insulte aux hôpitaux enfant
alors vous êtes de nouveau élu donc à
paris mais incapable d'imposer vos idées
et là il faut dire reconnaître que les
idées de victor hugo voulait imposer à
l'époque abolition de la peine de mort
aux états unis d'europe
on n'y est toujours pas instruction
gratuite et obligatoire
on y est presque et les droits de la
femme il faudra attendre 1945 pour que
de gaulle donne le droit de vote aux
femmes
les 35 heures vous aviez pensé non
qu'est ce qu'il ya et je n'ai fait que
le double ouais alors que mon corps et
je pensais pas pensé à ça on ya pensé
alors pour finir vous devenez sénateurs
et or là c'est incroyable
votre rue devient l'avenue victor hugo
c'est quand même classe l'an quand on
reçoit des des enveloppes avec marthe et
victor hugo
victor hugo c'est drôle on a
l'impression d'être enterrés vivants
ouais et heureusement personne n'a
jamais réussi à maintenir enfermés même
pas la gloire
guy bedos là tout d'un coup je me
demande si on n'est pas au panthéon en
train de parler avec victor hugo je
commence à y croire et je me sens pas
bien du tout justement justement victor
quand vous mourrez 2 millions de gens
viennent voir votre corps embaumé sur
l'arc de triomphe
il faut onze chars pour transporter les
fleurs quand vous a apporté jusqu'au au
panthéon
ils ont vous des différentes amines
sacré convention obsèques publié tout
seul témoin moi j'avais choisi le
corbillard des pauvres avant le reste
jusqu'au tenté ont réouvert pour moi
mais ce sont les politiciens et le
peuple était là il peuple c'est la mer
avant c'était parfait on aurait dit du
nedbank c'était cette ambiance glauque
avec 500 on aurait dit milliers de
francs merci beaucoup jean-claude avis
assault on regarde la maladie
bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]